Résilience.
Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Vivre, survivre, rester en vie.
Résilience,
cette capacité à rester vivant.
C’est déjà le nouveau défi de l’humanité,
de nous, en tant qu’espèce.
« Nouveau défi », pourquoi nouveau ?
Parce que nous sommes une espèce jeune
et déjà nous cherchons à rester vivants.
Résilience,
mais en avons-nous le monopole ?
Comment rester vivant ?
Comment, en tant qu’humanité,
trouver les solutions de la résilience ?
Peut-être en trouvant un modèle,
peut-être en trouvant des façons
déjà éprouvées de rester vivant.
Et finalement, qu’y a-t-il de plus
vivant que la vie elle-même ?
Qu’y a-t-il de plus démonstrateur
de cette capacité de résilience ?
Le biomimétisme, c’est cette idée que
finalement, on peut s’inspirer
de la vie elle-même
pour voir comment elle a été en capacité
de s’adapter, à rebondir, à développer
dans une sorte de course
d’optimisation continue.
Rien n'est figé dans le vivant.
Tout est en évolution
permanente, continue.
Comment est-ce qu’on s’inspire de ça
pour l’appliquer aux activités humaines ?
Comment on redécouvre,
comment on se ré-émerveille
de cette vie qui nous entoure
pour l’appliquer
aux enjeux de l’humanité ?
Parce que finalement,
cette vie qui nous entoure
a réussi à résoudre
les mêmes enjeux que nous.
Elle aussi consomme de l’énergie,
mais elle est économe en énergie.
Elle travaille en circuit court.
Elle fabrique des matériaux
à température ambiante,
à pression ambiante là où nous,
nous consommons beaucoup d’énergie.
Elle développe des symbioses
aux bénéfices mutuels.
La forêt va puiser
dans son réseau racinaire
des connecteurs qui s’appellent
les champignons mycorhiziens
pour se lier au mycélium.
Dans biodiversité, l’important,
c’est « diversité ».
Cette diversité
des essences et des espèces,
c’est ce qui fait la résilience
d’un écosystème.
Donc finalement, nous avons sous les yeux
ce modèle, ce cahier des charges,
à travers la vie, la nature,
la biodiversité,
tout ce qui vit, tout ce qui palpite,
tout ce qui respire,
tout ce qui gigote sur la planète
pour voir comment nous pouvons nous en
ré-émerveiller pour en tirer des leçons.
Mais, il y a un préalable
avant de démarrer ce grand voyage.
Et ce préalable, c’est que nous devons
descendre de notre piédestal.
Nous devons comprendre que
nous sommes un parmi une infinité.
Et que nous ne sommes pas
forcément les meilleurs.
On entend souvent, vous entendez souvent
dans les médias ou
dans des discussions avec des amis :
« Comment sauver la planète ? »
« Il faut sauver la planète. »
La vie existe sur Terre
depuis 3,8 milliards d’années.
Savez-vous quel âge vous avez ?
Probablement, oui.
Savez-vous quel âge nous avons
dans notre forme dite élaborée
d’Homo sapiens sapiens,
L’homme sage, on s’est auto-proclamé.
On a - allez - 250 000 ans.
L’Homme ne va pas sauver la planète,
c’est ça, le préalable.
C’est de reprendre notre juste place.
Ce n’est pas l’Homme qui va
sauver la planète,
c’est la planète qui va sauver l’Homme.
C’est la planète qui nous procure
les conditions d’une vie harmonieuse
si nous prenons soin
de préserver cet écosystème,
évidemment, de le protéger.
Bien sûr cessons de le détruire,
mais ce n’est pas l’Homme
qui va sauver la planète.
La vie n'a pas besoin de nous.
Peut-être même qu’elle se porterait
mieux sans nous.
C’est le point de départ
de ce voyage en biomimétisme
pour considérer qu’aujourd’hui,
le monde change, le monde évolue.
Ce n'est pas un drame.
La vie ne fait que ça.
C’est le principe de la résilience :
on s’adapte à un contexte changeant.
On est à l'affût.
On change.
Et donc plutôt que
de regarder le monde changer,
prenons conscience de la fragilité
de cet espace,
de ce monde, de cette planète.
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez
la photo que vous voyez ici.
Ce n'est pas une photo de Thomas Pesquet.
Ce n’est même pas
une photo de Neil Armstrong.
C’est une photo de quelqu’un
qui a précédé Neil Armstrong,
qui s’appelait Bill Anders.
Nous sommes sur l’équipage d’Apollo 8.
La mission de cet équipage est
de repérer des zones d’alunissage
pour le prochain premier pas
de l’Homme sur la Lune,
qui sera la mission Apollo 11.
Là, nous sommes en décembre 68.
Ils sont partis avant pour repérer
et donc ils font des rotations
autour de la Lune.
Et quand ils reviennent de la face
cachée, froide et obscure, de la Lune,
ils terminent cette première rotation.
Et qu’est-ce qu’ils voient ?
Ils voient cette planète.
Je vous demande juste l’effort
d’imaginer être dans cette
soucoupe en décembre 68.
C’est la première fois qu’un homme voit
la maison des Hommes, la planète Terre,
sans avoir les pieds sur Terre,
à cette distance-là.
Bill Anders est captivé,
d’abord par la beauté de ce qu’il voit,
et par ce qu’il mesure
comme étant une fragilité incroyable dans
cet océan de vide sidéral, froid, glacial,
évidemment dénué de toute forme de vie.
Il attrape son appareil photo
et met une pellicule couleur
pour immortaliser l’instant.
Quelques jours après, il développe
cette photo appelée «Lever de Terre» -
Earth Rise.
Et il apporte cette légende,
géniale,
frissonnante, émouvante,
plus intéressante, je trouve,
que le petit pas, le bond
de géant pour l’humanité.
Nous étions partis explorer la Lune
et nous avons découvert la Terre.
Fabuleux.
Nous sommes sur ce vaisseau.
Ce vaisseau est la seule forme
de vie dans l'univers.
Mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est que nous
n'habitons pas seuls cette planète Terre.
C’est ça aussi, l’autre grande
leçon du biomimétisme :
nous ne sommes pas seuls sur Terre
et toutes les autres formes
de vie qui nous entourent
sont de formidables camarades de classe.
Ce sont des cracks en résilience,
en développement durable,
en transition, en adaptation permanente.
Nous, 250 000 ans, nous sommes
une espèce en barboteuse.
Nous sommes les derniers
arrivés dans la classe.
Alors plutôt que d'essayer d'expliquer
à tout le monde le début du cours,
on se tait,
on écoute les petits camarades,
on a même le droit de copier,
parce qu’ils ont beaucoup plus
d’expérience que nous.
Toute cette nature que
nous avons perdue de vue,
que nous avons un peu oubliée,
que nous ne savons même plus reconnaître,
et donc a fortiori, que nous ne savons
même plus connaître,
a beaucoup de choses à nous dire
si nous prenons le soin de l’écouter.
C’est le point de départ de cette idée
que cette vie qui à 3,8 milliards
d’années d’existence,
c’est la plus formidable entreprise
de résilience au monde.
Tout ça se développe
dans tous les domaines,
et notamment en France.
Parce qu’on a de l’excellence
académique en France,
on a de l’excellence entrepreneuriale,
Nous sommes créatifs,
nous avons cette capacité à essayer,
à réussir parfois, à mêler les talents.
Regardez cette aile bleue du Morpho,
un beau papillon qui vit en Amazonie.
C’est une grosse bête,
qui fait la largeur de ma main -
presque -
d’un bleu iridescent.
C’est un bleu pour draguer les femelles et
dire aux mâles que c’est son territoire.
Il y a toujours de bonnes
raisons dans le vivant.
Mais d’où vient ce bleu ?
Ce bleu est une succession
de tuiles empilées en surface.
Ce sont quatre strates d’écailles
qui sont empilées de telle manière
que ça crée une diffraction de la lumière
pour créer ce bleu
sans pigments ni chimie.
Souvent le bleu et le vert dans le vivant,
on appelle ça
de la coloration structurale.
Mais ce bleu,
ce n’est pas le seul bénéfice fonctionnel
de cette accumulation de strates,
de cette nanostructure de surface.
Cette même organisation de surface
va créer une surface antibactérienne
car il ne supporte pas
d’avoir des passagers clandestins.
C'est lourd, c'est pénible.
C’est aussi une surface
qui est hyper-hydrophobe
car si les ailes sont
un peu humides et se collent,
il aura du mal à les détacher.
Et on est en train de découvrir
qu’elle a aussi des capacités
en auto-régulation thermique.
Autrement dit, à 45 °C,
ce papillon devient iridescent.
Si vous mimez la même organisation
de surface sur un matériau,
vous allez obtenir les mêmes
quatre propriétés fonctionnelles.
Appliquez ça par exemple sur des matériaux
qui sont exposés
à de fortes amplitudes thermiques.
Si ce matériau est capable de mieux
absorber la chaleur et d’en renvoyer,
il va moins se déformer,
il va durer plus longtemps.
Vous pouvez créer de la couleur
sans pigments, sans chimie également.
Regardez à côté, vous avez un ver marin,
on va passer de la terre à la mer.
Ce ver marin peut vous sauver la vie.
Il s’appelle Arenicola Marina.
Vous êtes passé tout à côté
sans le savoir probablement.
Une fois, même plusieurs fois.
Si vous avez déjà marché
à marée basse en Bretagne
sur ces petits serpentins de sable
que vous connaissez.
En dessous, il y a ce ver.
Ce ver a un secret parce que c’est
la marée qui lui apporte son oxygène.
Et donc à marée basse, il est en apnée.
Il est balèze parce qu'il est
en apnée pendant 6 h.
Quand la marée lui apporte son oxygène,
qu’est-ce qu’il fait ?
(Inspire)
Il fait le plein d'oxygène et il attend.
Et quand on étudie son hémoglobine,
elle nous révèle des secrets fantastiques.
Elle est donc super-oxygénée.
Elle séquestre 48 fois plus de molécules
d'oxygène que notre hémoglobine à nous.
C’est une hémoglobine extracellulaire.
Ça veut dire qu’elle n’est pas encapsulée
dans des globules rouges.
Ce sont vos globules rouges qui typent
votre groupe sanguin, votre rhésus.
Donc cette hémoglobine qui n'est pas dans
le globule rouge, elle est universelle.
Transfusable à l’Homme.
Vous pouvez la réduire en poudre, la
compléter avec du liquide pharmaceutique,
vous obtenez une poche de transfusion
pour sauver quelqu’un
alors que vous n’avez pas le bon
rhésus ni le matériel frigorifique.
Donc ce ver marin peut vous sauver la vie.
Ce n’est pas l’Homme
qui va sauver la planète.
C’est ce ver marin qui
va vous sauver la vie.
Ce n’est pas l’Homme qui va sauver
la classe des bons élèves de la vie,
c’est cette classe qui va
nous sauver si on l’écoute.
Nous aussi, nous faisons partie de la vie.
Nous sommes aussi biodiversité.
Vous avez au centre une rétine humaine.
Nous avons aussi une caméra.
Il n’y a pas seulement des caméras
sur ce que vous avez dans les poches.
Nous avons une caméra,
sauf que notre caméra à nous,
Elle est peut-être
un peu plus intelligente.
Notre caméra n'est pas une caméra
en flux continu d'informations.
On enregistre une information
et on ne l’actualise que si c’est utile.
Si vous vous figez tous,
et que quelqu’un ici se met à s’agiter,
à lever les bras -
on n’a pas répété, mais admettons -
je vais te tourner la tête.
Merci.
Parce que mon œil est un
détecteur de mouvement.
Regardez l'horizon.
Regardez la mer,
si une baleine à bosse sort,
évidemment, vous allez tourner la tête.
Nous détectons les mouvements.
Une start-up en a développé une
qui s’inspire de la rétine humaine,
qui est économe en énergie,
qui est économe en flux de data,
qui voit mieux les mouvements
et qui détecte mieux les obstacles.
Stocker, gérer de l’information -
vous voyez ces brins d’ADN au-dessus ?
Nous sommes de l'information.
Nous stockons de l'information
sur de l'ADN.
Figurez-vous - accrochez-vous -
que nous sommes en train de réussir
à stocker des datas sur des brins d’ADN.
Sur un encodage à 4 niveaux par rapport
à un encodage binaire, peu importe,
mais cet encodage
de data sur des brins d’ADN,
vous stockez vos informations,
vous les laissez à température ambiante.
Revenez dans mille ans,
vous les avez toujours.
Alors que nos serveurs, on doit
les changer tous les sept ans.
Et c’est la bombe énergétique
de demain, déjà d’aujourd’hui.
Le facteur en termes de
capacité supplémentaire,
c’est plusieurs millions.
On pourrait stocker toutes les données
sur l’équivalent d’une tablette
de chocolat de brins d’ADN.
Les exemples se multiplient
car on connaît de mieux en mieux le vivant
et on est de plus en plus capable
de le décrire en lui posant des questions.
Posez-vous la question : comment est-ce
que la nature aurait résolu mon problème ?
Est-ce que la nature achèterait
ce que je suis en train de produire ?
Comment créer un bénéfice mutuel
pour la nature, la planète et nous ?
Comment aurait-elle fait ?
Cela se développe car
la recherche se développe,
car les industriels s’y intéressent de
plus en plus pour réduire leurs impacts.
Parce qu'il faut créer ces ponts
entre recherche et industrie.
Les start-ups françaises commencent
à être vraiment intéressantes sur le sujet
et commencent à intéresser
sérieusement les investisseurs.
Mais ça nous amène aussi
sur une autre réflexion,
cette réflexion
sur notre rapport homme-nature.
Et finalement, petit exercice
en cinq étapes, très rapide.
Il était une fois, il y a longtemps,
une nature divine
pour laquelle on sacrifiait
l’humain à la nature.
Les Aztèques, au sens propre du terme.
Je ne dis pas qu’il faut revenir à ça,
mais vous aurez remarqué qu’entre-temps,
on a plutôt sacrifié la nature à l’humain.
La nature était divine,
on implorait ses bonnes grâces.
On se soumettait
à ces bonnes grâces des dieux,
parce que souvent chaque élément
naturel était incarné par un dieu.
Et ensuite, on va dire le néolithique,
il y a 10 000 ans, 15 000 ans,
nous nous sommes sédentarisés.
Nous sommes devenus -
Nous sommes passés
d’un peuple cueilleur, nomade,
à un peuple sédentaire
développant l’agriculture.
À partir de là, il faut essayer
de domestiquer, de dominer.
Il faut essayer d'irriguer des terres
pour y faire pousser des cultures.
Troisième étape : 1859.
Le colonel Drake fait jaillir
une goutte de pétrole.
La nature devient stock,
la nature devient valeur,
la nature devient objet de conflit.
Il faut l'exploiter.
Quatrième étape, on comprend
que nous sommes allés trop loin,
même si ça avait démarré déjà au 19e,
mais on accélère :
les aires marines protégées
et les parcs naturels.
Il faut conserver, il faut protéger.
Cette cinquième étape fabuleuse
que nous propose le biomimétisme,
c’est une étape dans laquelle
on se repose.
En tant qu’élève,
face à cette nature inspirante,
la nature devient modèle.
Mais pour faire ça, encore une fois,
il faut se remettre à notre place.
Il a fallu attendre Copernic
pour comprendre que la Terre
n’était pas au centre de l’univers.
Il faut faire notre deuxième
révolution copernicienne :
L’Homme n’est pas au centre de la Terre.
Accepter cette idée que nous n’allons
pas sauver la planète,
c’est la planète qui va nous sauver.
Cette planète est le berceau de notre
passé et le vaisseau de notre futur.
Bon voyage !
(Applaudissements)